[Music]
zach starts off this hour in evansville
indiana hi zach how are you
hey george and dave hey what's up
that's all right so i'm a catholic i've
recently had a few conversations with
other catholics on the topic of work
some of them have an almost socialist
perspective on it they think workers
today in the western world are facing
poor working conditions they argue for a
four day work week and they say their
employers don't care about them
in some ways i can understand their
concern as christians don't want others
to be taken advantage of however i
disagree with their position
dave i was wondering what you would say
to these people as someone who is
christian encourages hard work long work
when needed and as someone who owns a
business
well um
there's two sides to the equation
there's the employer side and the
employee side
i'm an employer
and
as a
person of faith that means i have a
responsibility
to serve
and treat my team well
okay
as a dad
i have a responsibility to
nurture serve and take care of my
children
when they're minors in my home
taking care of them also includes
requiring that they brush their teeth
that they say yes sir and no sir
that they say thank you
and learn gratitude
that they learned to work
loving them well my children when they
were little
included teaching them to work included
teaching them things
that if you were to ask them
when i was requiring them to clean up
their room when they were four
they could say
well my dad has unfair working
conditions
he's requiring too much of me at four
years old
but the truth is i could have cleaned up
their room easier than it was to talk
them into doing it
but then
they would have learned nothing and they
would have gained no dignity
as an employer it's different than
parenting
but uh there are some parallels in that
my goal or my job as a person of faith
is to serve my team but serving my team
also sometimes includes allowing them to
work somewhere else because they suck at
their job
we set them free in jesus name
i had a young man here that was in sales
many years ago and he um
he was really bad at sales
and we kept talking to him about it and
finally one of our leaders serving him
sat down with him and said you know
young man you suck at this what is it
that you want to do with your life he
said i really want to be a photographer
and we said okay well let me help you
show you how to be a photographer we
actually have a small business thing
here called entre leadership and we
coached him and loved him and fired him
because he was awful
at sales
oh by the way he's now a world-class
photographer
some of the album covers that you see
i'm from nashville artists the guy shot
but he sucked as a salesman
so that is you know what are unfair
working conditions that mean old ramsey
people fired me well you sucked and
guess what you went on to become the
best possible version of yourself and we
were loving you well when we fired you
we actually cared about you
when we were firing you
we actually cared about you
when your mama had cancer and we paid
for
your airline ticket to go visit her we
actually cared about you when we do all
these things to serve you and help you
and love you but we also actually
require that while you're here at work
that you work
and i don't really want to hear about
your whining in your social activism
i'll fire your little butt for that
so you know we're not going to unionize
it ramsay i can just promise you that
it's not going gonna happen i'll just
shut the dead gun place down
so you know here's the thing you work
you get paid you do the work you get
loved we love each other we're all
working together to pull off the same
thing i don't know why a bunch of adults
can't do this i don't know why we have
to juxtaposition
employers
against employees
in order to call that some kind of
spiritual movement the goal the truth is
we're supposed to love each other
i'm supposed to love them well and
they're supposed to love us back and do
their work
and um
it's not me extracting
from the labor market uh and not them um
extracting from me in the name of some
twisted form of fairness that they came
up with and somehow put jesus on that
that one's really ridiculous
but
you know some people can put jesus on
anything and put geniuses on a peanut
butter sandwich and call it theology
it's ridiculous but it's not theology
it's a peanut butter sandwich
so
um that's a brand new sentence for me
right oh gosh but yeah i mean so yeah no
i'm with you zack i mean you read your
little statement i disagree with your
friends it's not anything to do with
catholicism versus protestant i promise
i can't even say it protestantism it's
got it's got to do with a clean view of
scripture which involves loving each
other well
do unto others as you have them do unto
you treat your neighbor love your
neighbor as you love yourself the second
of the greatest commandments
jesus said to catholics and the
protestants
equally
and so you know this idea that all
employers are evil and should be
punished and all form here because for
some of these little snowflakes work at
all is unfair it's not fair that we have
to work to live dave it's unfair that
you require me to work while i'm at work
and i want to work from home where i
don't really work
but i'm at home
and i still collect a check
and oh by the way i've got three of
those work-at-home jobs now which means
i'm now stealing officially
from that employer
uh which is a new trend in work at home
by the way
go ahead and get three full-time jobs
while you work at home get paid by all
three of them for working full-time and
you're obviously aren't while you're
sitting on your
that's called stealing okay that's a
lack of integrity to say the least
you're a thief so all of that to say
zach this idea that socialism or
capitalism is either one the answer it's
not it's sanctified
capitalism meaning that people are
loving
the other person well
in the equation
i actually do love our team
and i actually have done unbelievable
sacrifices for them
and we proved that during our downtime
during covet as an example
where we said the first people that
aren't going to get paid if somebody
doesn't get paid is leadership it didn't
it didn't result in that we were able to
keep profits up and everybody was able
to get paid
but that was how we lined it out we said
the leaders go first
leaders go first leaders eat last
according to simon sinek but leaders go
first on not on taking the pain
and so you love your team well and in
return if you are an employer you should
work your butt off you should do your
work as unto the lord
3 23 in the bible okay here we go so i
mean do your work is under the lord does
that sound like do your workers under i
want to work four days a week and i went
did i have to work and i want to [ __ ]
and complain about my employer does that
sound like doing your work as under the
lord to me doesn't sound like it to me
so george and i were talking at the
break about that last uh caller and he's
telling me stuff that i didn't know
because i'm an old dinosaur apparently
that you said there is a uh whole work
uh anti-workers of the anti-work
movement
the group of people that think it is
unfair that they should have to work
and they're frustrated with the nature
of their employment
so therefore because i hate my employer
i should just not have to work the
nature of employment
okay
all right and if and if the young man
was asking me the christian
response to that um
you know uh
so here's what's interesting the
christian response is always
loving
but sometimes is so bold and in your
face
when you read scripture that it's
offensive
so like uh paul said in the bible though
he was instructing
those that won't work don't let them eat
so that would be a christian response to
the what's it called the anti-anti-work
movement yes there's a movement of
people that don't think they should have
to work that they should just be given
stuff by society
just because it's unfair and all working
conditions therefore are unfair
correct yeah
and there's i mean i just pulled up
there's about a litany of of scripture
that is very clear even without the
biblical context you know ephesians let
the thief no longer steal rather let him
labor doing honest work with his own
hands so that he may have something to
share with anyone in need
look at that or proverbs he whoever is
slack in his work is a brother to him
who destroys
and i love there's one that i always
think of when i'm grilling
um
and it's uh
i can't remember the scripture because i
can't quote it exactly but it basically
says
a a an unfaithful servant is like smoke
to the eyes oh
you know you get the smoke in your eyes
and your eyes are watering yeah and so
when you have an employee
that is an idiot
it's like the grilling and the smoke is
in your face you know i mean it's like
that's what you're dealing with and so
if you've got an employer that's an
idiot it'd be a similar thing i'm sure
but oh my gosh
this is a song compared to the you know
talking about the anti-work movement
proverbs 14 23 and all toil there is
profit but mere talk tends only to
poverty
sounds like there's a lot of talk out
there dave well the the thing is
um
you kind of just have to back up and go
okay if i was
your dad and you were doing that and you
were under my control i mean if you were
a teenager in other words you weren't an
adult living on your own then you get to
do what you want when you do that i
guess but but if i if i was someone who
loved you
and could influence you because i loved
you and i wanted what is good for you
then i've got to look at you and go
kind of have a dr phil moment here i
mean like how's it working for you
how's that working
this is not working thing how's the not
working thing working for you
you know and um you know because you
kind of do that like with communism or
socialism you can go around the world in
history and look and go where there has
been communism where there's been
socialism you just look at them and go
so
you know how's that working for you
like when you're driving through israel
okay
uh you you go into the areas that are
controlled by the jewish community
they're
prosperous safe
clean you're going to the areas
controlled by the plo
looks like a trailer park
it's awful
and you just kind of want to look at
them and go guys how's it working for
you
you know how's that working for you
what's the fruit of
your ideas
when you put your best idea forward and
you get poop back
how's that working for you
you know how's the thing not work thing
working for you yeah
man because you love somebody i don't
want you to you know how's the being in
debt thing working for you it's not
that's why you called us we're gonna get
you out of debt you know so yeah
and to your point you talked about
parents and how you know you make your
kids clean their room and it's forced
labor or whatever it is the thing about
working
you can't choose your parents but you
can choose your employer
so imagine that you can just
choose to find a place that doesn't suck
i don't think they pay enough okay don't
go to work there
if you think you're worth it i think
they're a toxic work environment that
guy's a narcissist everybody's a
narcissist now everybody that you don't
like is now a narcissist
that's a redefinition of that term
anybody i don't like narcissist that's
how you define it
so uh yeah i and so don't work there
don't have a choice don't work there
you don't no one forced you to work
there half the show is just telling
america that you have agency over your
life you have control
but the problem is people back
themselves into a corner and decide they
only have one option it's to work for a
toxic place or not work at all
and that's just not the case no it's not
true there's a lot of wonderful
organizations that exist in capitalism
and treat their people well including
their customers
and do a great job
are they perfect no they're not perfect
institutions they're run by human beings
and they're but they're all over the
place and i know a bunch of them
and if you think you could do better go
start you a business and run it the
right way we need more of that in
america go for it yeah take that take
that um
not working thing and go hire a bunch of
people with it
and see how that works out and pay them
with the not money that you don't make
here we go
great business model
love it uh so yeah in those hungry
people that need to be fed
um
you're not gonna be feeding them because
you ain't gay money
your generosity level because you're a
broke person
by the way all communists are broke
people
they generally happen because there's
nothing more capitalistic than a
non-broke communist
um they all need to we all need to read
a rabbi lapin's book yeah thou shall
prosper
and it'll give you it'll give you a real
spiritual look on work the jewish
community he talks he's orthodox jewish
rabbi he talks about the jewish
community the work the hebrew word for
work and the word for worship is very
similar he said on sunday we have
worship service and on monday we have
customer service
and they're both worship
they're both workship so when you are
working and doing your work as under the
lord
it is honoring it's an honoring thing
spiritually you're honoring god with
that so uh you're to sit on your butt
and scream about everyone else and gripe
about everyone else
there is nothing christian about that at
all i think that's called gossip
so anyway it's very interesting
discussion it's a fun life mission i
guess to be angry at work and just
strike no it's not fun because they're
angry all the time being angry all the
time is not fun well that's why reddit
exists dave that's where they all go
twitter twitter and reddit twitter
well at least you have a place to vent
and and someone can pretend to care but
and it's free so that's nice but you
know the whole thing of i'm gonna that's
why you know i've had i've turned off
twitter i don't i don't look at it
anymore because there's nothing on there
but anger and i don't i quit watching
the news i don't i don't turn the news
anymore i just um if you're not on
twitter you don't have to block people
so that that's i don't know that's the
downside you had some fun with that
that's the downside i had the record for
most blocks a guy reached out and dm me
and said hey why did dave block me as if
i i have the race you're one of forty
thousand dude i mean something you said
was pretty offensive you're not special
you're not that special
but you know please unblock me i don't
know i'm not even on there anymore just
forget it go on to something that's
relevant to your life and twitter is not
on the list
so yeah it's this is an interesting
discussion though yeah we're babbling a
little bit because there's a lot of
emotion around i just did not know there
was a real thing i mean that's from the
bbc they did a huge piece on it a real
thing called the anti-work movement
that's like the
man you could have an anti-anything
movement that's right that's pretty cool
but i think everyone needs to read ken's
book from paycheck to purpose if they're
you know in this world because what
we're saying is work is not evil
work is actually good for us and we just
need to find the right kind of work at
the right place let me just tell you
that
there is nothing
the human psyche is built to have
traction
there is no
psychological benefit to doing something
that has no traction work involves
traction that's why i like pressure
washing you get to see the stuff clean
up while you're doing it it's why people
like to mow grass you get to see when
you're done you gotta do it again next
week but you get to see when you're done
right it's it's you know when you're
doing something you need to feel the
sense of accomplishment and traction
incremental progress along the way it's
a psychological need that the human
brain has
and to actually do nothing
is psychologically
suicide
because your your brain is going to rot
inside your head so that that's it
really doesn't work on so many levels
psychologically economically spiritually
and that's why you're loving heavenly
father gives you instructions to work
there we go good word there's your
sunday summer movement is not biblical
there we go ding ding that's a headline
dave be careful this is the ramsay show